bladesmiths I'm going to be testing the
strength and durability of your Edge by
taking each of your knives and chopping
into these solid brass rods
if your knife is Tough Enough and your
Edge was designed properly they should
hold up Josh ready
all right
[Music]
good job
Josh and the brass Rod he'll tear your
knife out bad there's a little wrinkle
but other than that there's no chip
still Sharp
good job Paul you're up you ready swing
it hard all right
Paul your handle feels really good but
we have some pretty significant blade
damage right here
overall good job thank you Liam ready
yeah all right
[Music]
so Liam we've got a little bit of edge
deformation it's almost not noticeable
it's still sharp there and that tells me
you got a good heat treat on it when I
feel a handle like this it feels good
but it's a little skinny up here tends
to wanna can't like this
overall great job thanks Doug
Lane Smith's the gesture blades Edge and
sharpness I will slash across this fish
if it's sharp it should cut through Josh
you're up first you ready yeah I'm ready
well Josh your blade is light it's fast
and it's sharp sliced all the way
through this sir
we'll cut
good job thank you Paul you're up next
you ready yes sir let's do this
nice job
nice clean cut Paul
your Blade's got some meat to it some
power this sir will cut thank you
Liam you're up next you ready oh yeah
foreign
[Music]
Liam your blade design definitely makes
it like a chopper The Edge is sharp as
you as you can see cut all the way
through
the handle is a little bit small and
rounded but nonetheless this sir will
cut awesome good job
gentlemen judges have made a final
decision about which of you is leaving
the forge
Paul
[Music]
your blade did not make the cut Paul you
made a pretty good comeback from round
one however your heat treat was still
the problem the blade wasn't hard enough
and that's why we're sending it home
very understandable
Paul please surrender your weapon and
leave the forge
my first canister experience was a pain
in the butt I wish I would have heat
treated that thing the first time
correctly
I didn't win but hey I had fun I'm still
Paul happy
I'm always happy